as you may have noticed there have been
one or two things happening in the world
of AI this week we've had a bit of time
to take it in but of course it will take
weeks and months to test everything out
let's bring you some of the best bits
now though from a custom GPT I made to
the interestingly named new gro gaus and
Olympus models whisper V3 better text a
video an AGI tier list from Deep Mind
and much more but I'm going to start
kind of randomly with the update to how
current chat gbt is we're also updating
the knowledge cuto we are just as
annoyed as all of you probably more that
GPD for's knowledge about the world
ended in 2021 we will try to never let
it get that out of date again gp4 turbo
has knowledge about the world up to
April of 2023 and my only comment on
that is that this means that gp4 has
knowledge of itself for the first time
while gp4 was trained in August of 2022
it wasn't released until March of 2023
so GPT 4 should know a lot more about
how it's trained and some of the latest
advances in AI but how much can the new
GPT 4 Turbo process at once well 128,000
tokens which is approximately 100,000
words in English gp4 supported up to 8K
and in some cases up to 32k context
length but we know that isn't enough for
many of you and what you want to do
gp4 turbo supports up to 128,000 tokens
of context that's 300 pages of a
standard book 16 times longer than our
8K context don't assume though that just
because it can process that many words
that it will be equally accurate at
comprehending all of them this analysis
from yesterday showed that when you're
trying to retrieve a fact from a
document particularly one of more than
about 80,000 words or 100,000 tokens if
you placed that fact at between 10 10 to
50% through the document retrieval
started to get pretty bad if the fact
was towards the end of a document or you
submitted fewer words or tokens
performance was much higher the good
news though is that GPT 4 Turbo the 1106
preview is much better than previous
iterations of GPT 4 at retrieving facts
from those context lens so yes even
though performance does degrade the more
tokens or words you submit it's better
than before but again better than before
still isn't even close to perfect
surprising no one Dolly 3 gp4 Turbo with
vision and the new text to speech model
are all going into the API today and I'm
going to give you a taste of the kind of
things these new apis unlock we have
this implementation by Robert luk kosko
integrating GPT Vision API and allowing
you just to clip out bits of a screen
and ask questions about it I'm
interested in and the gb4 is going to
going to answer me what is it it's hip
joint region and what about this part
what is it I'm not giving it even any
context it just knows this is shinger
equation let's try this part what is
it potential energy
term and not say I'm really into the
cars but I I I I don't I just don't know
what is this your orange stick what is
this orange
stick and an oil dipstick what about
webcam GPT I think the kind of people
who will use this are those who want to
maximize their productivity and they're
going to get their webcam to check if
they're working of course let's hope
that companies don't use it as they have
been known to do to monitor their
employees and we also got a new text to
speech model which people are already
integrating with GPT Vision can you
believe this he's taken on the whole
defense he's a one-man Show Ladies and
Gentlemen he shoots go messy messy messy
unbelievable what a goal what a goal
glorious absolutely glorious the stadium
explodes in Joy this is football magic
at its finest and then of course we have
whisper version 3 which can understand
speech and convert it into text models
like whisper V3 and conformer 2 will
change how we use the internet in the
not too distant future speaking of new
modalities we're also releasing the next
version of our open-source speech
recognition model whisper V3 today and
it'll be coming soon to the API it
features improved performance across
many languages and we think you're
really going to like it this chart shows
the word error rate across a range of
languages for whisper V3 and V2 a drop
means an improvement and surprisingly
English isn't the most accurate language
if you happen to speak Dutch Spanish or
Korean you might be in for a better time
of course if you speak one of the lower
resource languages like Bengali it might
be a bit harder to use use just quickly
though I did pick up on this somewhat
brief remark Sam Alman made about GPT 4
Turbo being smarter GPT 4 Turbo is the
industry-leading model it delivers a lot
of improvements that we just covered and
it's a smarter model than gp24 I've
started my own investigations as have
others and the results aren't uniformly
better and in fact for some use cases
gpc4 Turbo performs worse this was a
test for sat reading by Jeffrey Wang
there does need to be far more thorough
investigations but I wish they released
some benchmarks along with that claim
and there were two moments from the
guest appearance of the CEO of Microsoft
Satya nadela that I found particularly
interesting first he promised open AI
the most computes the systems that are
needed as you aggressively push forward
on your road map um requires us to be on
the top of our game and we intend fully
to commit ourselves deeply to making
sure you all as Builders of these
Foundation models have not only the best
systems uh for training and inference
but the most compute so that you can
keep pushing appr forward uh on the
Frontiers because I think that that's
the way we're going to make progress why
is that relevant because it seems at the
moment every Mega Corporation in the
world is going to come out with their
own language model many of you may have
seen the publicity over Gro from xai
it's been trained on Twitter and
apparently replies to more spicy
questions tested the new grock one
across a range of benchmarks although
some people have complained about the
settings they used either way on these
benchmarks it did seem to be somewhat
firmly beating GPT 3.5 the original chat
GPT but notice that on these benchmarks
it was falling way behind Claude 2
that's on the mlu testing for general
knowledge human eval for coding and gsmk
for mathematics they also gave this
human graded evaluation comparison on an
exam produced after after all of these
models were trained and on that grock 1
outperforms even claw 2 and way
outperforms GPC 3.5 now many have
complained about the way that the models
were evaluated but I've talked before
with smart gbt about the discrepancies
that can arise with human grading and
automatic grading this just reaffirms
the need for me for new authoritative
hand graded benchmarks pricey but well
worth it and they're not the only one
with Amazon building a model called us
which apparently is going to have two
trillion parameters this article says
that's twice the size of gpc4 but
according to what I've seen it's more
like about 10% bigger problem is of
course it's not all about the parameter
size it's about how you use those
parameters so I don't personally predict
that the Amazon model will be more
powerful than gp4 and even Samsung are
getting into the game with a model that
can also produce text code and images
that's apparently going to be
incorporated into their next round of
phones and I will be there to test it
hopefully but back to the open AI Dev
day where they confirmed that we can now
use different modalities of gp4 all in
the same window chat GPT now uses gp4
Turbo with all the latest improvements
including the latest knowledge cuto off
which will continue to update that's all
live today it can now browse the web
when it needs to write and run code
analyze data take and generate images
and much more and we heard your feedback
that model picker extremely annoying
that is on starting today you will not
have to click around the drop down menu
all of this will just work together I
decided to test that out and ask three
things in one Allin one prompt I asked
use Bing to get the live market cap of
Microsoft and Apple then use code
interpreter to calculate the percent
difference I definitely don't trust the
base gp4 to get that calculation correct
and then I asked output an image that
captures which market cap is bigger now
of course market capitalization changes
all the time but the these figures are
broadly accurate and this apple figure
is indeed 5.32% bigger than Microsoft's
figure but it was the final part
incorporating darly 3 that I found the
most impressive it created the image you
can see here with the Apple skyscraper
being slightly bigger I would argue
around 5% bigger than the Microsoft
Tower albeit with the hallucination of
an A in Microsoft it was around this
point in the presentation that samman
mentioned AGI but before I take a look
at that comment and a new AGI tier list
paper from Google deep mind I thought
we'd take a brief interlude and enjoy
this incredible update to Gen 2 from
Runway
[Music]
ML and at the end of the video you're
going to see an even more impressive
demo I think of this technology but just
before we get back to Sam what do you
think about a physical device for video
editing generated by AI this is called
the first AI
[Music]
machine
[Laughter]
[Music]
now here's samman's quick comment to SAA
nadela on AGI well I think we have the
best partnership in Tech I'm excited for
us to build AI together no I'm really
excited have a fantastic thank you very
much for coming that brought to mind a
paper I read from Google Deep Mind this
week it's called levels of AGI and it's
very much based on the idea of the
levels of autonomous driving and I do
admire their intent to create a more
clear definition of AGI for example
level two competent AGI level four
virtuoso AGI with so many AGI
predictions out there as shown in my
previous video clear definitions are
quite important but I do have some
questions for the authors that I would
want clarified for example they say
competent AGI which has not yet been
achieved is when the AI is at least 50th
percentile of skilled adults that
compares to emerging AGI which is equal
or somewhat better than an unskilled
human and in one of their later examples
they talk about mathematics but what
counts as being skilled in mathematics
are we talking about being better than
the median high school graduate in
mathematics being better than the median
college student in mathematics or are we
talking being better than the median
professional mathematician to me they
never made that clear and it makes a big
difference to The Benchmark if we're
just talking about those graduating high
school or secondary school gpc4 is
already better than the median person
there in mathematics if we're talking
about Elite professional mathematicians
when it's better than the 50th
percentile of those we are getting
really close to Super intelligence also
the authors confuse me somewhat on page
seven when they said this a competent
AGI must have performance at least at
the 50th percentile for skilled again
not defined adult humans on most
cognitive tasks so it's not about being
average at all tasks it's apparently
about being average at most tasks but I
could well imagine a situation where say
GPT 5 is well above average for 90% of
tasks but its capacity for purely
abstract reasoning is down at the 10th
or 20th percentile and even though that
would meet this definition of a
competent AGI many people would say it's
not really AGI in that scenario it
wouldn't fundamentally be understanding
what it's performing so well in so again
definitions really do matter and this is
a step forward but doesn't go all the
way to a solution for me I did also note
this on page seven the rate of
progression between levels of
performance and or generality may be
nonlinear not in a straight line
acquiring the capability to learn new
skills
May particularly accelerate progress
toward the next level going back to that
table I think that's something really
worth noting imagine a virtuoso AGI
that's better than 99% of skilled people
across a range of domains but those
skills would include machine learning
chip design curriculum learning and of
course that virtuoso AGI can just be
duplicated so there's a billion of them
running and surely a billion virtuoso
agis would be able to create the next
level ASI much quicker than they
themselves were created it seems like
others are getting that sense of
acceleration too with the co-founder and
CEO of Runway ml as we've seen saying
decades worth of progress happened this
year a Year's worth of progress is now
happening in months months worth of
progress will start to happen in days I
personally don't think we have quite
reached that point in AI but the
momentum is definitely building going
back to the paper toward the end it read
a bit like a screenplay for X-Men
talking of artificial superintelligence
the paper said non-human skills that an
ASI might have could include
capabilities such as neural interfaces
perhaps through mechanisms such as
analyzing brain signals to decode
thoughts oracular abilities being an
oracle perhaps through mechanisms such
as analyzing large volumes of data to
make high quality predictions or the
ability to communicate with animals that
would be amazing perhaps by mechanisms
such as analyzing patterns in their
vocalizations brain waves or body
language the paper also talked about the
level of autonomy that we might give to
AI again graded across five levels but I
bet David Shapiro has got something to
say about the possible societal scale on
Wii that's boredom or Lethy that might
accompany expert AGI that drives
interaction with humans only providing
guidance and feedback anyway let's get
back to what you can do now which is
create your own chatbot your own GPT I
luckily got Early Access to this and
have been playing about a bit with it
first thing I did was create a bot of
Ivan ilich the star of an amazing short
story by tol sto The Death of Ivan ilich
all I did was create a description and
instructions for gpc4 Turbo and created
an image of Ivan ellich with Dary 3 I
gave a knowledge of the entire short
story by just uploading a document with
the short story I think I'm allowed to
do that in terms of copyright but
copyright doesn't seem to mean Much
Anymore anyway all I wanted to really
demonstrate was that this Ivan ilich bot
would know the story better than bass
GPT 4 for example here is normal GPT 4
for how many days did Ivan ilich scream
in the famous short story The Death of
Ivan ilich it seems to think I'm quoting
a document and says error reading
documents but anyway can't answer the
question that short story probably is in
its pre-training data but it can't
retrieve the information well enough but
my Ivan ilich bot can even with such a
direct question as for how many days did
you scream acting in character it said
for the last 3 days of my life and that
is correct based on the short story what
I'm now working on probably with
thousands of other creators is an AI
explained bot getting the transcripts of
my video and turning it into an
imitative chat bot I asked well myself
what sort of timelines are people using
for AGI and drawing on one of my recent
videos it outputed a fairly decent
answer as you might expect I've been
testing out many of the other gpts
including those made by Third parties
but honestly the open AI gpts don't seem
that much better than the generic
version for example I tried out the math
mentor and it couldn't seem to answer
math questions any better than generic
GPT 4 I also tested the meme GPT and it
didn't seem to understand any more memes
than the Basse GPT apparently later this
month we are going to get a GPT store so
there should be many more gpts to test
out soon according to Sam opman bringing
in just a smidgen of hype all of these
developments are just the start as
intelligence gets integrated everywhere
we will all have superpowers on
demand we hope that you'll come back
next year what we launch today is going
to look very quaint relative to what
we're busy creating for you now thank
you so much for watching to the end of
the video and I'm going to leave you
with this creation from infinite yay
they use mid Journey the new Runway and
stable audio have a wonderful
[Music]
day